so yeah it's a little-known secret or
it's a little known fact that i've
i've been a monk in my life but i've not
just been a monk once right just saying
that is so cool
to me this is just part of buddhist
culture so in buddhist culture
um normally when you want to give your
family like good karma
everyone in my family has been a monk
like twice in their life
once when they're a teenager and once
when they're like
an adult so you you you become a monk
like
once when you're when you're like a
teenager we call that being a nain
and then there's you become like a full
monk when you
become an adult and that's when you kind
of hit like your early twenties
okay okay so yeah so normally a lot of
people just do it like for like one or
two days because
we believe that it's good karma yeah um
i remember when i was
about 12 or 13 i i was a monk for two
weeks
and then afterwards when i was about 22
23 i was a monk for a full month jeez
yeah yeah cause i cuz i cuz you told me
stories about how you were a monk for an
entire month but i never knew that you
did it twice
oh yeah yeah i mean i mean to me it's
just not part of like being a buddhist
and
you know trying to get i was trying to i
was that good little asian kid i was
trying to give like my
family good karma and everything but i
honestly i honestly
like rep the experience because it was
i'm not i'm not joking when it was
literally
the life-changing experience for me like
that was it that was me
before being a monk and then there's me
after being a monk
because normally people just do it just
to you know
uh just to impress their family and just
give give their family good karma
but i i told my mom if i'm gonna do it
i'm gonna go all the way like yeah yeah
like there's there's there's some
temples that you go to that don't take
it as
seriously and then i i went to a [ __ ]
hardcore temple where
you know we didn't have any technology
yeah uh we had to
okay so here here was my daily schedule
okay so i would have to wake up at
around
4 a.m that already sounds like 200
that already sounds like like like have
have to be ready
have to be completely ready by five okay
and we didn't have any beds we had
a concrete floor and one little pillow
to sleep on oh my god and we had like
the thinnest blanket in the world which
wasn't so bad because it's thailand but
when sometimes when you're sleeping in
the middle of the forest because there
would be times when we just go out to a
temple in the middle of the forest
it can get [ __ ] cold there the
temperature drops to about
two or three degrees sometimes and and
like you you just have this like tiny
little blanket on a concrete floor
to keep you warm right so we'd have to
wake up at four get ready by five
and then we'd just be like meditating
and praying for a good two
three hours every day and then
afterwards
we would basically go out barefoot go to
like whatever village or
whatever area around the temple um and
people would just donate donate the food
to we
would have these we would carry like
these little baskets um
on our necks and people would come over
and they would
you know donate food or whatever they
want to donate because we believe that
if you give to a monk that's good karma
as well yeah yeah so the food that we
got donated that's
what we would eat so we we would walk
around for a few hours
then for the entire day yeah for the
inside or was it like just like enough
or
i mean you you get what you're given
right
you had no choice about what you could
eat you could eat basically what you
were given did you ever get anything
like super nasty
no i mean it's it's i guess in the
mindset
you're not like picky and like oh really
a snickers really
no the whole point of being a monk is
that you don't okay
you don't care like you you you eat to
survive i guess if you're caring about
that that's like no
that's that's that's defeating the point
of being a monk so you
you get what you're given and you you
live the simplest life you can possibly
live and you basically
eat to survive and you get one meal a
day and
you gotta you gotta be okay with
whatever you get given so we would
eat at around 11 to 12 o'clock and that
would be our first
and only meal a day it was it was easier
when you're a kid mug because kid monk
should get two meals a day
okay yeah but when you're an adult yeah
when you're an adult when you're more
grown up burning through more calories
nope
you gotta survive on one meal a day and
afterwards you could you there was no
cheating so after that you couldn't have
any milk or any like liquids that
had calories you could only have water
water or some kinds of fruit juices and
and that was it
and yeah it was it was very
i i i don't know really how to ex
describe the experience because imagine
if you just take
every every distraction out of your life
yeah and you just live the simplest life
possible you don't need to enjoy
your food you know you you get you don't
really get
the pleasures in life but at the same
time you just kind of
you're okay with everything because you
have you have to be okay with everything
and i remember for the first
week of being a monk it's [ __ ] hard
it is so [ __ ] hard to reprogram your
brain
to not only be like okay how do i
distract myself with my phone how do i
not check twitter how do i not watch
youtube videos how do i just
be okay with my own thoughts and just
and and it's so hard because your brain
nowadays your brain constantly
constantly looking forward to something
yeah
it constantly needs something to
distract itself um
and the first week i was just you're
kind of like a drug addict right
i'm sorry i should tweet give me a tweet
i'm i'm sitting there trying to meditate
and my mind's just going out a million
miles an hour
i haven't watched tv in in a week i
haven't seen a screen in a week it's
it's very very difficult but the more
time you do it the more you kind of your
you realize that oh this is this this is
all
these are all just distractions you can
be completely okay with just yourself
and your own thoughts and just doing the
simplest things
and life activities and then when
i got to that point i kind of just had
time to just reflect
on my entire life because what else what
else what else are you gonna [ __ ] do
when you have
nothing to do but literally think back
about
everything every decision that you've
made in your life and the way your mind
works
you know you know when you're sometimes
you're like lying in bed at 11 a.m and
your
brain reminds you about that shitty
thing about that embarrassing thing you
did when you were 12 or maybe like
that time when you punched a [ __ ] kid
in front i'm like oh my god i got him
good
so just just imagine your entire day
just being that
just being like ah i wonder if i made
the right choice at this point in my
life
and then what happened to me was that i
kind of just reflected on
every every little decision that kind of
that kind of led me up to this point in
my life and what it made me
what it forced me to do was really think
huh am i
really happy about where i am now like
what what's what's my life going to be
like out when
when i when this monkey ends and
i was at a really bad point in my life
before i became a monk which is kind of
why i've really wanted to
commit to the fact of being
like if if i was going to be a monk i'm
going to go all the way
get the full detox yeah get the full
detox you know because i've seen some
temples you you walk in and they have
like a flat like a 50 inch flat screen
and i'm like this is the monk channel
only we only have the mung channel this
doesn't seem very
monkey to me i don't know about that
except paypal you turn the tv on it's
like a live stream of like a different
temple and then like
praying exactly nice nice content
so so it forced me to just reflect my
entire life and it forced me to really
think about what i wanted to do
after my monkey had ended so it was
truly
a i don't want to say [ __ ] it was a
spiritual journey and i really just
discovered
i mean i think in this instance you can
because it but it really sounds like
it kind of was i don't know you're like
it's it's like me when i go to the
toilet without my phone
i am free yeah i'm kind
because because people have talked to me
about how they have you know
how they've had similar experiences when
they just shut off social media and
everything like that yeah
and i'm just like you know no you're
already yeah
brah brah you don't even know
get on my level yeah get on my level bro
like you didn't have any board games you
didn't have any cards to just
play around all you just had was just
yourself and and it's just
it i can't really convey how alien that
is
because it it was alien for me as well
it was a part of me that just a vision
like you know because as you said the
only thing you had was just yourself and
your mind right yeah yeah and
all i could imagine was just monk gone
just sitting there and just thinking up
with funny jokes
i'm gonna roast these noobs when i get
back good roast oh no no no
that that that's that totally happened
as well that's when i was a monk that's
when
i uh thought about hmm there's a series
i want to make called anime in minutes
i remember the exact moment because i
was i was just walking around
um walking around one of the thai
villages and
it just it just it just [ __ ] came to
me because i i taught i remember
last uh not last week but a few weeks
ago i talked about being zen
on the [ __ ] toilet and then shout out
yeah so that was that's kind of like
i i kind of sometimes when i'm just
walking and i'm just
you know just zoning out sometimes i've
reached this
point when a lot of ideas just come to
me and it came to me when
i was a monk as well and i had i got a
lot of video ideas
and a lot of a lot of ideas when i was a
mum
which which which it was it was these
ideas
when i was a monk that have developed to
me like to my comeback on youtube
where i figured out okay if i'm going to
come back on youtube how i was i was
going to come back on youtube yeah
but yeah this has been a very closely
guarded secret because
you won't there are some there are some
youtube some very old youtube clips
where i'm just wearing i'm just wearing
a beanie and nobody knows why i'm just
wearing a beanie
and it was because it just i had just
finished my monkey and i was just
completely bold
yeah what if they just like took it in a
really dark direction it's like oh no
the cancer treatment yeah yeah how do
you like sign up to be a monk you just
is it like a facebook group you're like
i wanna i wanna be a mother
you know like how do you just yeah just
like rock up and be like yo
let's do it like yeah i mean you just
turn up to whatever temple you you want
to
do and they they're like okay uh you go
to the head monk and you request to be a
monk
and they ask okay before you become a
monk you need to make sure you have you
have no outstanding debts
you basically you've got to give up all
material
connections to the world before you can
commit to becoming a monk and you'll
have like this interview
where you're like okay if you're gonna
become a monk you gotta make sure
yeah do this do this do this you know
you know what would be a really cool
idea for
this channel is if like us three somehow
went to like a temple here
and just like experienced it for like a
single day wow
already on that [ __ ] hey if you guys
would like to see that
monk episode monk episode like god could
be like head monk of trash case it's
just [ __ ] like you have to shave our
heads did you realize that jerry
[ __ ] i just know i can do it all over
again i can commit to that
i know you caught your long hair i can't
commit to that i'll just wear the beanie
but like i i don't really talk about it
but now that now that i am i do
like highly recommend that kind of
experience or just
or just do it doing that kind of
experience because you don't notice
how like how distracting life is like
just
like you don't you don't realize that as
soon as you wake up you got things
to occupy your mind yeah you got your
job or you got
you know you wait you've the first thing
you do is you check twitter
open arc nights and you don't you don't
know how crazy your mind can be
sometimes so you literally remove
every distraction every commitment that
you need to do from your daily life and
you just have
you just have nothing because it's just
it's just a void right
you're just giving your life a void and
because you give your life a void
it [ __ ] changes you i i don't know i
don't know how